taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
hey taste buddies it's the taste buds
podcast i'm joe
sal today's debate is
egg salad versus tuna salad
send out it's out there baby it's out
there all right it's live on twitter
you like the floor the thanks voting
joining us everybody yeah by the way
it's just been we've been having a blast
doing this and i just gotta say
we read the comments and there's nothing
i love more
than seeing you guys literally like take
our
our our our arguments seriously and
speak about the foods and speak about
our debates and how we bring up the
the points and and and the merits of the
food a lot of times you guys bring up
great points that we didn't even get to
within our 30 minutes
it's just great i agree i just think the
the the the comments
and and and you guys are like you add so
much to it
i agree we've been loving reading what
you've been posting yeah i know we make
we obviously we joke a lot about the
critical
the criticism comments and stuff that's
just but there's because it's funny to
make jokes about it but like there's
so many so much of the comments i love
all the comments
negative positive whatever thank you for
commenting but uh
i uh i really do i'm i would say i am uh
it warms my heart to see how invested
some people get in the debates
i've had so many friends call me at this
point
yeah and say to me dude i love the show
more than any other podcast probably
that i've ever done
because this is just striking such a
that's not to disparage any of my other
podcasts it's just it's just this is
strike
a chord with people it's really fun when
it comes with food you know when it
comes to food
so people are really just like you know
my friend scott said to me
he's my oldest friend of the world i've
known him literally my entire life and
he's a big
jokers fan by the way i hate him
um but he has said to me he was like
dude
this is he goes i've always been very
excited about what you're doing i've
always been very proud of you as my
friend to watch you do your thing
he goes this is the first thing you've
ever done that i was
jealous of because i was like i
i want to do this like i want to argue
food like this like this is like people
just get you know what i think it is
everybody if you if you put two options
in front of someone
they have an opinion right so it's as
relatable as that if
i if i pass someone on the street
talking about two food items i'm
immediately gonna be like oh i agree
with this or that
so that's what we kind of were hoping
that you guys would latch onto and it
seems like you are
so for us it's been it's just been a
thrill to read the comments and how much
you guys are appreciating it yeah it's
why we did it so
and by the way uh just to balance the
scales here
uh we talked on the show about how bill
burr
sent sal some uh encouraging words
supporting his oreo argument
argument against my chips ahoy argument
bill
also sent me some encouraging words
saying that i turned him on ice cream
sandwiches
and that he went out and bought a box of
traditional ice cream sandwiches
and has been eating them nightly
all right i mean i don't know if that's
a good thing
it's great if he just just balloons up
wouldn't that be so great yeah
oh that would be amazing people i do see
in the comments so people like i
couldn't
like i literally as i'm reading this i'm
going to drive to this place and get
this or
i got combos i haven't had them in
forever or i'm after
i listened to this i went right to
wendy's or whatever it is you're just
naming the ones you want
yeah yeah yeah no but but people have
been saying that they
actually it's moving the needle as far
as like them having these
these foods yeah so pay attention
sponsors
yeah pay attention yeah i actually got a
text from my buddy sean monahan
who again a very old friend of mine uh
and uh we don't talk frequently
but he's a guy i knew since high school
and and uh you know i usually see him at
christmas time every year and
uh and we drop a line here and there
throughout the year but uh i got a text
from him out of the blue
where he was just like combos comes
in big bags you're a hundred percent
wrong like i'm getting texts like that
from people that i do not speak to on a
regular basis
full investment into 100 100 yeah every
week i get a handful of texts
from a variety of people immediately
weighing in
on on the food it just people can't help
it
i love it by the way crazy you know who
loves the show tim
robbins tim robbins the actor from
shawshank redemption
yeah i i know who he is but i couldn't
think that you meant him
it's not true i just made it up but
wasn't that exciting for a second
was it
it's not out of the realm of possibility
you are an actor
it's not out of the realm of possibility
that's so that was so
the the choice i'm sorry no the choice
was so specific
at first i thought you meant um who's
the ladies man
i'm so sorry meadows fantasies yes for
some reason i don't even tomatoes for a
second
but um tim robbins when was the tuna
salad invented
tuna salad has been eaten for over 100
years i can't believe it's only that
long
the first written reference to tuna
salad in america appeared in 1907
and by 1914 dozens of recipes have been
published tuna salad especially with
celery
is similar to chicken salad while also
being much cheaper a fact that helped
its early rise in popularity wax okay so
this makes sense
this is like right leading into the
great depression basically
that it rose to notoriety egg salad
if you want to read that sure uh i got a
i got a ric flair issue
uh who invented there's a ric flair
statue in front of my television screen
blocks have it uh who invented egg salad
but mayonnaise as we know it today was
reconceived by the great chef
marie uh antoine
did i say that right yeah you got me man
in the early 1800s
oh wow so egg salads older prior to then
compost
composed salads with layers of
ingredients including hard cooked eggs
like today's chef salad
or enjoyed as dinner dishes in the 17th
18th century
salad has dinner wow yeah yeah
and the chef's salad which you said
sucked yeah the chef's salad isn't
the chef salad is i want a sandwich i
don't have bread um
all right i'm taking egg salad in this
debate oh and that's if we
sorry if we didn't if the salad one
didn't air yet
that was just we didn't say the winner i
know i know i know all i said was that
i know we're just out but just before
they light us up yeah
there could be no existence outside of
this episode uh but that doesn't say
when
egg salad was invented that just says
that mayonnaise
as we know it was invented in the
eighteen hundreds when was
egg salad invented seventeen
sixty-two christmas eggs excellent is a
egg salad sandwich is a simple and
humble uh american sandwich dating back
to sometime
in the 1800s but not before 1762 because
that's when the sandwich was formally
invented it consists of a combination
of hard-boiled eggs mayonnaise salt
pepper between two slices of bread nice
and simple all right so folks let's
start the debate
i am taking the winning
side of this debate tuna salad
so for some reason
decided he wants to argue egg salad
because
okay i will say one thing though well
the reason we did tuna salad versus eggs
i think they're very comparable
both are polarizing dishes because i've
heard from many people that they
despise detest and are grossed out and a
lot of it might have to do with mayo
but from tuna salad and egg salad so
people a lot of people i i feel like
when they get this
oh neither you know sure this is people
typing
but i'm prepared i'm prepared yeah
to give you the floor first yeah by
starting with one question
sure i defy you yeah to tell me
any use for egg salad
outside of between two slices of white
bread i don't think
you can eat it you can eat it with it
without bread you know what are you
gonna do
this this guy's this there's not
versatility without bread
yeah in your life because you get it
when you get in the deli they put it in
the cup
right and you bring it home and
sometimes i'll just scoop and eat it
okay so you you will just eat up the
thing
okay yeah especially i don't i i know i
don't eat bread that often so like
but um but egg salad you know what it is
guys
i i just i don't know if it's done right
this there's been gross egg salad right
there oh yeah and it's been gross tuna
salad
but when excel is done right when it's
not for me i don't love it too creamy
i like nice big chunks of hard-boiled
egg and it's the perfect just kind of
mix
and it's like not nothing too heavy a
little salt little pepper
right maybe you put it on a nice some
nice
nice two wheat slices of whole wheat
fresh bread with a little lettuce for
crunch
and it's just i think it's just a really
something i don't have all the time
and and i'm always like when i remember
to have it i was like
oh egg salad oh yeah i have an egg salad
sandwich i get excited
and and i think it really tastes good
i really do i just i just like it and if
i had the choice
between the two sandwiches more so than
not i would take egg salad over tuna
salad
i have issues with tuna salad um
those being okay i think every anytime i
order tuna salad no matter where i
am who i'm with if i'm at someone's
house if i'm making it on my own not so
much
but if i'm going to a deli especially
and i order tuna i feel like it is a
full on roll of the dice every time i
never feel
i think you're you think you're you
think you're on a safe number on the
table with egg salad
i don't really that is you're crazy
you're rich egg salad
at like a like a restaurant whereas like
tuna salads on
like diner men no actually no i think
i'm more rolling the dice of tuna salad
let me expound to this day even if i go
to the best like
diner like if it's not consistent like
tuna salad is not necessarily always
consistent
and i feel like i could order tuna salad
and get something i don't know if it's
good until i bite it so every time i
experience a
can tuna salad make you sick a study in
the journal of american medical
association details the growing problem
of histamine poisoning caused by tuna
i'm not even i don't get that yet
histamine poisoning causes rash diarrhea
cramping vomiting a tight feeling in the
throat facial flushing a headache
symptoms that are disabling but
temporary and usually not fatal
tuna salad can just basically bring you
to the brink of death
i bet egg salad can too egg salad should
be discarded if left out for more than
two hours at room temperature
two hours this is your window
the fruit fly this is your window
an odor a flavor of appearance or mold
it should be a thanks
okay i just want to point it as mold
i just want to point out this is the
trash
that is eating egg salad that they have
to tell you hey if there's mold on it
you shouldn't need it
they have to let me just go back i have
to tell the egg salad eater
and if you see mold you shouldn't eat it
all right
i could be in a in a five-star diner
okay
and and i go i say to them
i'm contemplating the two in the mouth
i'm contemplating the tuna salad
sandwich
is the tuna salad fresh and they'll
usually be like
yes or let me find out for you which
means that they
actually hold on to tuna salad that the
actual
worker might not deem fresh themselves
tuna salad
overstays its welcome in that capacity
once i got tuna salad we made two days
ago it should still be good they'll
still serve that [ __ ]
hold on hold on here's why i don't know
i just wanna
order the tuna salad i'm always like
well it's going to come down to the
first bite
i've ordered tuna salad bit it and like
nope here's why i just don't like that
point you just made
as the proprietor of a sandwich shop
pop-up okay
i check the tuna salad daily to make
sure it's good
so does the guy nobody but not everybody
holds this honestly
let me make my point now so does the guy
who's behind the counter
whatever on whatever day that is we
check it regularly
now if i had a diner that i owned
that was running 24 hours with a
constant rotation of wait staff and
cooks and everybody else and managers
i would say whenever somebody orders
tuna salad you have to check it first to
make sure nobody
forgot to check it i don't think that
that's that weird of a thing
i'm so happy that you would do that
hypothetically but i would do
life and in my whole life what do you
mean hypothetically i would do it i know
but
people don't do that is what i'm saying
and that's why and there's an inherent
problem
with tuna salad not to mention it's eggs
no it is a two
hour window sandwich right
it's a fish you're gonna knock fish
sandwiches now no but it's
like it's like it's like what
chopped up fish it's tuna on bread
it's the fish but if you think about it
it's this is the
fish fish it's chopped up this is not
what this is
it's chopped up tuna fish
mixed with mayonnaise on bread
yeah and yours is a miscarried baby
wow chicken well no it's un un mixed
into basically carried it's not
miscarried it's not fertilized
it's not a miscarriage okay it's killed
it's an abortion
it's not it's not it's not killed yes it
is
it's not a sound an egg is a it's an egg
that yeah did you ever read
animal farm they take the eggs from the
hens and they so they can't hatch and
they can sell the eggs that's what it
but it's an egg is it killed isn't that
egg just unfertilized
no eggs at the grocery store are usually
unfertilized
so it's unlikely they'll hatch i don't
understand what's going on here
sometimes
i don't understand i'm basically you
just say what comes to your mind
you're like a ghost i'm basing it on you
can't do that i'm basing it on what they
said an animal farm oh
great let's just base everything on they
take their eggs
they take their eggs at animal farm and
they they sell them instead of letting
the hen sit on them until they hatch
but this is the real world we're not
talking about animal farms
you want to talk to us about charlotte's
web next what do you want to talk to me
about a george orwell book that hasn't
come true
in order to make some money to buy food
and keep the farm going squealer
announces that the hens must give up 400
eggs a week
the hens consider this murder so they
begin to lay their eggs in the rafters
and smash this is what you're basing
your egg salad sandwich on
you son of a [ __ ] what are we talking
about i'm
you're arguing squealer squealer
announces the hens must give the eggs
i mean what are you talking about look
here's my i want to take a minute and
talk about
uh one of our sponsors uh and i'm
excited about this because i
loved and love cereal
so much me too man growing up and fun
cereals
yeah fun cereals fruity cereals
chocolatey cereals i love these kinds of
cereals frosted cereals
uh and i've had to cut them out of my
diet
in later i think everybody has this is
the thing cereal is a top three food for
me heartbreaking
i like peanut butter and jelly ravioli
and cereal yeah
yeah that's right like i i do not get
cereal anymore
because it's literally probably the
worst thing you it's just sugar in a
bowl
basically this is going to blow you guys
away
so there's this this this cereal called
magic spoon you you've just had it right
joe
i did i uh i had four boxes of this sent
to me
a coco flavor a fruity flavor a frosted
flavor and a blueberry flavor
uh it is a keto friendly cereal zero
sugar
11 grams of protein three net grams of
carbs
with each serving it's keto friendly
it's gluten free it's grain free it's
soy free it's low carb and gmo free
uh so i had four these four flavors sent
to me last night i ate so much of it
that i made myself sick yeah which is
from
not for the magic spoon but because
you're not supposed to eat four boxes of
cereal you don't need all this
yeah and i eat four bowls of cereal
because that's
that's how good it is it was delicious
and i wasn't excited about this stuff i
want to keep trying it cereal is back in
my life now i don't know how you make
cereal with zero grams of sugar
and and protein and carbs but it and
have it taste good yeah
that's the whole difference here this
was my favorite thing about it and this
was my
worry and the worry was put to rest
immediately i was scared that it was
gonna taste
diety right uh and i don't like that
flavor usually
uh i do very much like diet coke
but uh that's the almost the only
anytime i eat anything that's supposed
to be like a dessert kind of thing or
or you know they try to unsweet things
replicate
right what it tastes like never do it
right
yeah this did not taste like that to me
and i ate this
by the way with no fat soy milk
so i ate this at the least fun level
possible
and i was over the moon i loved it so if
you want to try this and i suggest you
do
you got to go to magicspoon.com taste
buds
you can grab a variety pack the four
flavors i mentioned blueberry
fruit frosted and cocoa and you have to
use the promo code
taste buds at as well at checkout you're
gonna save five bucks off that first
order
yeah i mean and so that's important it's
it's not just entering the promo code
tastebuds but go to magicspoon.com
taste buds and then enter the promo code
taste buds this is another thing right
in case you're even weary at all about
trying it
magic spoon is so confident the product
it's a 100
happiness guarantee they call it so
doesn't matter you don't like it any
reason zero questions asked 100 of your
money back yeah
so i mean how can you lose really right
there that's magicspoon.com
tastebuds and then use the code taste
buds
to save five dollars all off cereal
is back in my life now sally babe hey
this is it oh we got this is how how
nice this is joey roses
aka joe derosa's sandwich shop has
brought a platter of sandwiches
a platter of sandwiches for us to eat
and taste it now
because of the nature of quarantine i
have not been down to the shop this is
gonna be my first
bite your first one
and i've plugged the sandwich pop up
many times we're at the stand in nyc in
union square
uh every week always follow the
instagram at joey rose's hard eight
i'm glad that during covet too you bit
it and then put it right down on top of
a plate of clean sandwiches
jesus christ we're at the stand in union
square every week
where does bread from we make it what
we make it we make it in hotel we make
it in house
quality stuff eight sandwiches for eight
bucks a piece you can't beat it
these are cheaper than going to subway
and it's ten times the quality
so i mean come on down enjoy us
i'm not cutting around this is dull
absolutely delicious like
home run quality ingredients they fill
you better
they taste better they are better joey
roses we do quality
better that's right sandwiches elevated
a brand based around phallus talk
put it in your mouth how dare you
talk about how gross tuna salad is when
you're talking about something that
comes out of the hole
of a chicken okay it comes out of a
chicken hole
and you crack it open and mix you're
chopping up the whole tuna hole's in
there somewhere i mean come on no you're
not chopping up the whole tuna you're
gutting it you're cleaning it yeah but
guess what's going in there the whole
area is going in
let me ask you a question you know what
i've heard and and and maybe we put it
together
i've heard this okay i heard that
without a doubt every can of tuna oh
there's nothing i don't like there's
nothing i don't like okay
don't get off don't get up don't talk
about the dolphins
don't even bring up the dolphins don't
breathe cockroaches bro
i heard though i heard that there are
cockroaches in
every single can of tuna that you buy
can we do it
food product maker hagaromo corpse said
thursday that is sold
that it sold a can of tuna that
contained an insect believed to be a
cockroach which apparently got inside
during the manufacturing process
the can of chicken sea chicken tuna was
produced in december
but that's one instance i heard warning
cockroaches seafood problems
okay seafood might be a little too
too broad but i heard that cockroaches
in factories get into the tuna and get
canned with the cheese in a second
how do they know if the eggs are
unfertilized because they don't hatch
what do you what are you
do you want you want to i mean should we
just break have a birds and bees right
now
all right fine i'm listening to you
listen tuna salad is
let me get cockroaches not on open food
but just i would put
cockroaches in cans of tuna oh you did
you wrote it
this is that that's i'm telling you i
read this man
i'm telling you i love how because you
read it in some
football zine it's it's it's it's fact
but i read it in a george orwell book
and it's
oh let's let's read this okay okay hold
on okay this was my point this is the
point i was gonna make okay
tuna and cans of tuna have uh this is
what i don't think i don't like
they don't say that's right salad eggs
they don't
sell cans of egg salad bro an egg comes
out of a chicken right
and then they go all right you got three
weeks pal three weeks that baby's fresh
otherwise
get it out you know what they do with
tuna i'll go downstairs you think none
of those fertilized eggs are getting
sent off to the market by accident
you don't think that's ever happened no
you think someone's going to crack an
egg and a chicken pops out
some of those i think some of those baby
chicks are getting murdered that's all
dolphin and tuna fish canned tuna does
not contain that was your own argument
okay no because the problems the
dolphins just get stuck in the tune and
here's my point this is my point i'm
trying to make
an egg comes out of a chicken's hole
right they stamp it three weeks it's
right on the thing you eat it's fresh if
not you throw it away
tuna i'll go downstairs and get a can
right now there's a fish
swimming they take it they chop it up
they throw in a can
they put 2028 on that can well you could
open a can of tuna in
six years from now and eat tuna dead
fish in a can for
six years is insane as you
i i think about that every time i bite
into a tuna but why
why researchers discover that tuna and
swordfish are eating microplastics
contaminated with harmful chemicals for
the first time
plastic particles have been found in the
stomachs of tuna and other fish
which is a staple we're not talking
about environmental science here and and
and we're talking about which tastes
better and which is better
but i promise you nine times out of ten
you order
you go into a corner deli of average
nature okay nothing schmancy
you order the tuna versus the egg salad
nine times out of ten that tuna's gonna
be better
the tuna the tuna
i think it's easier to make egg salad
let easier to make eggs out
you've got a hard boiled egg first
process i mean
the the the the the uh the chance that
you might make it like
mess it up i just think tuna because you
need good fresh tuna dude i
i'm telling you the reason i bring up
the packaging is cause i think tuna has
a stigma to it
and when i bite into a tuna sandwich
sometimes and it doesn't taste
great the first things that flood
through my head are how old is this tuna
how long was it in the can how long was
it sitting out
oh this is like these are your
mayonnaise these are your things but you
stop and
you go and you bite and you go i'm
chewing on fish with
mayo on it i'm i'm hold on
i'm chewing on a fish that was caught
six years ago
with mayonnaise on it this has nothing
to do with but think about that but i
don't the egg my egg
was my egg was too is is it's fresh
okay okay so i can make this i can make
a similar argument when you're eating
egg salad you think
this came out of a chicken's hole last
week
and then they chopped it up and put it
in it's equally as disgusting that's not
what we're discussing
the tuna and egg itself are polarizing
foods today we are discussing
the the which is the better and i am
telling you why tuna
look this this sentence will my opinion
closes the argument
you go to any sandwich shop tuna fish is
on that menu there is a tunas
outstanding you go to any classic bagel
shop
tuna salad is on that menu white fish
salad
salmon salad they're all of the same ilk
okay
egg salad you are coming across not only
rarely
okay but when you do come across it it
is a
dice roll and a half it is and you know
that it is and you know that that's true
but i think that's because of the mayo
and i think then that's consistent in
both sandwiches
but if you take away the mayo which is
consistent in both that may be good or
may not be
a rotten egg did you ever smell bad fish
of course
okay i smell as bad as a rotten egg i
disagree wholeheartedly
a rotten egg will a rotten egg turns
black
rotting fish we used to we had a
in in college we we had a teacher we
didn't like
and we put frozen fish we in the in the
ceiling tile
and then put the ceiling tile back and
then for the rest of the year hold on
i'm not talking about you put
you put perishable food up into a
heating duct that's not what i'm talking
about i'm saying
just in the refrigerator just in the
refrigerator when tuna goes bad versus
when egg goes bad
egg you open the you open the door the
entire
tuna tube of apartment or house can't
say i cannot smell it you can't say it
to me i will say tuna's not as offensive
when it goes bad tuna a rotten egg's a
rotten egg i mean i get it
there's a reason why every single fart
powder in fart spray smells like rotten
eggs and not rotten tuna
i know but you know what though rotten
tuna smells worse to me stink bombs
are modeled after rotten eggs not rotten
well i think it's a billion dollar
dollar idea there of a stink tuna bomb
because
i think it's not or they would have done
it okay how is tuna killed
oh my god they have prolonged and
painful deaths
prolonged and painful once the tuna out
of the water
fishers typically
club or stab them with harpoons in an
attempt to kill them
we don't know that this is true as
you've said about the things we've read
on the internet
in past episodes we have what is the
source of this
where is this coming from
that's how they invented the tuna club
oh god
i'll be here where is this coming from
how many
eggs you're going to hatch in the
grocery store can you hatch
okay all right can you hatch an egg
bought from the store
yeah according to joe derosa you can i
want wait no
here's here's what i want you to uh
google pip
is it inhumane to take eggs away from
chickens
i want you to google that because the
animal writes people well i'm sure we'll
have something to say about this if it
is
is it okay to eat eggs from chickens
raised in the egg industry
so yes it does hurt chickens when you
eat eggs the vast majority of chicks
sold
as backyard hens come from the same
hatcheries that supply factory farms
meaning they never meet their mothers
the male chicks are killed at birth
and they are equally genetically
modified i hope you're happy
this is what you're doing to young
chicks they're talking about taking kids
from their mom
well that's majority of chicks
sold his backyard hens come from the
scenes no that's not the same thing
hurts them emotionally it sounds like to
me that's that's when you take their
children your eggs mourn the loss of
chickens of eggs your chickens like
beep that do eggs do chickens
do check it do chickens mourn the loss
of eggs it was right down just scroll
down
oh my god i can't talk a little further
is eating eggs a sin
no no keep going there you go right
there
can you blow ken's relationship with her
eggs
chickens like all animals have a
language unique to their species each
sequence of sounds that they chirp cluck
and crow should be reading here
you know what just enough enough
enough what's better xl tuna salad
hens have emotional distress when you
steal their children
you keep your salad you keep bringing up
the the humanity of them
it says they beat them to death the tuna
well hens are attached to their eggs and
as george orwell wrote they don't like
when you take them away
it's not nice all right i don't i think
you recover quicker from biting into a
bad egg salad sandwich them from biting
into a bad tuna salad there's
listen i associate two i associate tuna
to um
food poisoning we can't fish man
fish is the number one tuna do chickens
get it no no don't go back to it now no
no no no
no no no we're off of the chickens get
attached
you just stay with me
sitting on one or two eggs when she
first starts if you want to hatch
chickens naturally you need to gather
eggs from some of the other chickens
and put them under you're allowed to
read the thing that despite you didn't
let me read the
the argument you only read the counter
argument you only read the counter
argument
you know what i don't need to let's get
down
i thought i heard a tuna being clubbed
let's i hope one is getting clubbed down
there
it's all something delicious to eat when
i go downstairs
i will say this let's get down the brass
tacks we cannot base this entire debate
on which one is worse when it's bad
let's talk about which one is better
when it's good
and tuna salad you know it and i know it
on a nice
crunchy crispy roll with lettuce tomato
salt pepper oregano
some provolone cheese bacon since you
love that so much as we know from one of
the other episodes
kick ass kick ass and you know
put bacon on a egg salad sandwich before
i put on a tuna
give me a break you want to put pork on
your fish
you wouldn't that's weird to me bacon
and eggs babe what are you crazy you
think that bacon eggs don't go
together better than tuna and eggs i've
never played
you know what i can go for a tuna an egg
a tuna a tuna and bacon sauce i'm not
saying i put bacon on every tuna
sandwich i'm just telling you that it's
pretty damn
good you ever see someone go oh man that
smells delicious what is that tuna
no you don't yes no 100 someone doesn't
go someone
no one ever goes oh my god you know what
that smells like 100
i have i love it it smells like tuna i
have gone to restaurants because they
had amazing tuna salad and said oh my
god this is this tuna is unlike anything
i got anywhere else
what restaurant did you go to for the
carnegie deli
carnegie deli i would go to often and
get over the corned beef and pastrami
which they were known for
and get the tuna salad so there's their
chicken hair pickles you can put on a
tuna set it's oh my god you ever have a
dill pickle on tuna salad also you know
what i don't like i don't like i love
the consistency of a hard-boiled egg
but i don't like the consistency of tuna
it's like this
mushy stringy kind of tuna
wait a second hold on a second you want
to go down this route you want to go
source material route
okay because i'll talk to you about tu
tuna tartar all day long i mean if you
want to go that route
we can but that's not what we're talking
about we're talking about salad versus
salad
a hard-boiled egg is not too it's not
egg salad no no no
but but it's it's but it is the main
ingredient of an egg salad sandwich so
i love i love white albacore tuna and
that solid tuna steak cut up into pieces
yeah and i don't like the consistency of
tuna i don't like the way it feels in my
mouth
i i don't mind like a hard-boiled egg is
actually kind of fun there's a little
bit of give to the
egg white but then you get to the yolk
it's more dense it's like a fun thing
you know i love biting into an egg white
matter of fact a hard-boiled egg white
it's a blast it's so funny what we're
discussing it's kind of like salt
that's not what we're discussing it's
part of the consistency of the dish when
i bite into it and one of the reasons i
like it that's not but that's not
how is it not part of the discussion i
don't like the mushy sticks but you're
not stringy
okay what about when you need a tuna
steak that's the that's the difference
a hard-boiled egg is to a tuna steak
what egg salad is to tuna salad a
hard-boiled egg is two-way
no you're wrong boiled eggs are in egg
salad
tuna steak is in tuna salad you gotta
chop them up you gotta chop up
hard-boiled eggs
when i eat a bite of tuna steak it's not
necessarily the same to me
you're reaching on this tuna out of the
can is a strawberry
no if you get solid white albacore tuna
out of a can it is solid
when you open it you have to break
you have to break it up you have to
break up solid white albacore tuna
i don't like the consistency what do you
want me to tell you no you don't like to
see a regular tuna
and i'm saying you can't argue the
consistency of a hard-boiled egg versus
the consistency of tuna
unless you want to let me argue the
consistency of a tuna steak versus two
this is another one
of the points you're making that are
incorrect
it's not incorrect hard-boiled egg is
the main
ingredient in an egg solid white tuna
solid meaning
solid piece of tuna is the main
ingredient
in the tuna salad i make but when i open
up a can it's all chunkified no
because you're buying chunk like tuna
that's not solid white albacore
it's a different type okay that's what
i'm saying to you
but i buy solid white albacore i'll
i want to please please take me to a
grocery store i want to buy up
can of salad alcohol and open opening in
front of you tonight so you can see what
i'm talking about we have plans tonight
now all right
all right fine let's go to the comments
i'm gonna take a beating on this one
this is like asking someone whether or
not they'd like to be shot or stamped
i know i said this to you guys yeah i
knew people were going to be like
what why egg salad get real be regular
eggs or be nothing
all right shot or stabbed as a content
contender for winner
one time in fifth grade 15 years ago
during a standardized test
he had extra breakfast came out looking
like an egg salad
well never look at it yeah but that's
not fair
oh that's beautiful but that's so unique
to you tuna
salad is bad enough without smelling
like someone's bowels
oh tuna salad is bad wait go back up you
say like satuna
in yourself this is funny that's funny
uh
voted tuna here however i make tuna with
egg in it oh my god
holy [ __ ] we didn't even we didn't even
realize that i never that is
frequently done i've never heard of you
with an egg in it yes i've never heard
of that in my entire life that is
frequently done
who would do that button
tuna salads with mad old bay seasoning
pepper salt lemon okay on jewish rye
salad says i'll be in my trailer mr
spielberg tuna salad says
i'll be in my trailer propped up on
bricks in the trailer
oh wow that's good yes that's very good
that's very good both are gonna make me
porcelain punisher both of you are gonna
make me the porcelain punisher okay
i'd rather die i know pipe down with my
own opinion but this is too gross to let
slide
oh either of those i really like tuna i
hate fish we'll eat all the tuna
but my grandma had a slam and egg salad
life changing
and everyone complaining about the odor
i recommend probiotics
uh honestly i think you can for the most
part
level the same pros and cons to both
might as well go with that tuna goodness
penny says i predict this will be the
closest poll yet people will either hate
them equally or love them equally i
don't necessarily disagree with that
egg salad all day tuna salad smells like
chinatown at high noon in the summertime
they're not wrong unacceptable and
edible give me that egg salad
all right and one last one they both
stank lol
but i can't do the egg salad the smell
immediately makes me want to vomit
all right very good let's see who oh and
our winner is
the trailer guy yeah uh follow aka the
baron
at aka the baron on twitter once again
egg salad says i'll be in my trailer mr
spielberg
tuna salad says i'll be in my trailer
prepped up on bricks in the trailer park
i live how do you feel
give me just a projection what do you
think i think tuna's gonna win i like
1040 votes i do like egg salad don't get
me wrong but i think tuna is going to
win
because of its staple it's just a staple
it's it's everywhere i think tuna salad
is just the more popular
all right this i think tuna's going to
win i hope
maybe it's close
also this goes by decimal place so
that's a legitimate 50 50. it's not even
50.1 to 49.9
it is 50 50 dead heat
at the 8 314 votes
that is insane so it's a draw
it's our first ever draw penny was right
all right
so mark it down pimp mark it down and
this is one that we will revisit with a
guest
to do a tie breaker whoa all right i
mean
dude this goes by decimal place jesus
all right so we will revisit
tuna versus egg salad with a guest to do
to be a tiebreaker
i i mean that's incredible i mean
that was a dead here we had it we had a
debate i don't know if it came out yet
that was 51.1 to 49.9 and we
said it's impossible to get any closer
but we weren't realizing is
50.0 to 50.0 i mean this is
wild now we are up to we're up to eight
almost 8 500 votes here
it's 50.0 to 50.0 excellent
tunisia and and i thought that you were
going to win i really did think i
thought so i thought i'd win by like
maybe five
ten percent like crazy oh my god
wow well that's a surprise and a half
that's great so do we both still just
love each other then
yeah i still love you i love you too all
right great holy so it's a draw
that's a draw we'll revisit it folks i
did not think at the thousands of votes
a draw would ever be possible
and they said it couldn't be done but
here we are by episode nine we're
breaking new ground
all right leave it there don't refresh
it again let's just leave it
we will revisit that's the show joe
derosa comedy on instagram and twitter
joey rose is at the stand in new york
city wednesday through sunday
we'll see you and how pat walsh and i
debate horror and genre films
uh available on patreon.com for new apps
back catalog available wherever you get
your shows
so uh if you guys are liking these uh i
know we tweet about them every monday at
11 but the real
way to do it is just subscribe or you
know follow
uh if you're watching uh audio or
watching here subscribe follow and rate
us
and then it'll just come into your inbox
every week so we don't have to remind
you and that'll help us because the more
subscribers we have
the more we can push it guys so if
you're liking it help us out by doing
that
no pressure network on youtube uh and
then if you have the community app
text me seven one eight two six zero six
six one nine at savilicano on all
socials
and that's it taste buds they coming to
the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds if you don't want your purse
they'll take your pay stubs